occupants in the car leave your heads
outside the car we know there is a gun
in there if you reach in that car
you may get shot so be careful a
terrifying traffic stop that stemmed
from a simple typo video shows Texas
authorities holding a family at
gunpoints for what they believed was a
stolen vehicle instead it was human
error
[Applause]
Arizona to the AR and that's what
happened yeah
can I explain to you the incident
happened on July 30th in Frisco Texas
about half an hour north of Dallas
that's when an officer spotted a black
Dodge Charger with out-of-state license
plates when the officer ran the numbers
she mistakenly entered the abbreviation
for Arizona instead of Arkansas leading
her to believe the vehicle was stolen
good morning
[Music]
51 can you read guys
2010 for all occupants are sitting still
in the vehicle and stay alive
inside the vehicle was a married couple
their son and nephew investigators later
learned they were traveling to the area
from Little Rock Arkansas for a
basketball tournament body camera video
shows officers give the family
instructions after the vehicle is pulled
over
all right
whatever is in your hand put it on the
roof that's fine open up the car from
the outside
yes
hey move your car back
move your car back bro I don't want them
to hit me
open up your car door and step out of
the car
unlock your car
unlock your car do it now
unlock your car slowly exit the vehicle
face away from us
face away from us face away turn around
turn around
an officer can be heard instructing the
family members to get out of the car and
show their hands
it's okay turn around do not face us
everybody in the car heads outside the
window
hands outside
maintain your hands outside
driver slowly lift up your shirt only
for us to see your waistband
slowly spin around you can lower your
shirt a little bit lower your shirt
lower your shirt we do not need to see
your bra
okay
that's fine slowly start walking
backwards
walk backwards keep walking keep it
walking backwards keep walking keep
walking keep walking
walk a little faster the tollway is shut
down keep walking backwards
keep walking keep walking keep walking
keep walking backwards keep walking
stop stop
away from us face away face that
direction
somebody else whose hands
Sandy Creek hey who
is nice I can't see who's on the
passenger side of the second car in the
Queen's car go ahead and call him out
with the microphone it's loud
[Applause]
okay
rear passenger behind the driver's seat
open up your car door and step out of
the car slowly
step out of the car
face away from us
face away thank you
with one hand
lift up your shirt so we can see your
waistband
now slowly spin around
slowly spin around higher lift your
shirt higher lift the back of your shirt
higher turn around now turn around
that's fine meanwhile a separate officer
speaks with the vehicle's driver who
assures officers the vehicle belongs to
her
back
[Applause]
come on sit back here
is this your car yes
come back here what happened is that
your tag on the vehicle yeah I'm from
Arkansas A Little Rock I'm a nurse I've
never done anything in my life
so we're so did you where'd you get the
tag from has that always been the same
tag on the vehicle yeah
so you always had that title man I've
been out ever since I've had my car okay
I'm from Little Rock Arkansas I've never
been in trouble
the woman explains to officers why her
family is in Texas from out of state she
continues crying as officers approach
her son
[Music]
look at my baby
baby
as long as your kids
I need you to talk to me my son and my
nephew we're on the way to a tournament
okay where
Frisco no no Grapevine Grapevine Field
House
whatsoever
[Applause]
let me explain to you why everything's
happening the way it is okay so we're
tag does not come back to that vehicle
it says like potentially Arkansas has
removed he says uh potentially Arkansas
I transferred my registration to my new
city Brian
so it's Arkansas has told whatever
Arkansas registration people that that
tag does not associated with any vehicle
officials then ask whether there are any
weapons inside of the car
stay on stay where you were at do not
move do not move
hey find out if there's any weapons in
the car
[Applause]
yes it's locked in there yes
in the glove box officers be advisors
weapons in a car
she's saying
officers then make very specific
commands for the people still inside of
the car occupants in the car leave your
heads outside the car we know there is a
gun in there if you reach in that car
you may get shot so be careful do not
reach in the car
all right sir that is on the roadway
with your hands up great shirt gray
shorts
slowly step backwards
start stepping backwards to our car
start walking keep walking keep walking
keep walking keep walking
who's on hands
stop stop hey we need more officers
at this point officials still believe
the vehicle was likely stolen when
discussing the registration the
responding officer accidentally mentions
Arizona instead of Arkansas
back to what I'm saying when I ran your
tag it does not associated with any
vehicle
years
I ran it and then I asked my dispatcher
for Randy and they told me the same
thing which is why I wouldn't just drive
with you for a reason so I want you
we're doing this because we want to make
sure more in the car isn't stolen or
anything so we get paperwork in there
we'll check and make sure everything is
good
forever I just refined it sounds like
you need to go have a conversation with
Arizona
or Arkansas the only thing I can say is
I just transferred my registration to
Bryant Arkansas it was a
[Applause]
since my car before that
it's your car though that's my car okay
you have a driver's license
[Applause]
[Music]
terrible I understand yeah you've never
been in trouble today and fight me go to
a Christian Stone okay nobody's in
trouble
where's the registration
in the front my keys I fell out you're
gonna have to take the key out of the
unlock button in the same box as the as
the firearm yes
I'm scared of it I just have it for safe
is it the key is what opens up yes
when I unlock the lock the button with
you have to clamp it and pull it out and
then you get the key
meanwhile the driver's husband explains
the family is headed to a basketball
tournament before he begins crying I
miss him listen sir this is my wife's
car we're just a bat in a basketball
tournament yeah
[Applause]
listen bro we just hit for a basketball
tournament bro we just learned we just
learned right now that's why we stopped
come on out come on up please
you fit that way or no
come on man I'm a basketball coach
look listen look at this bro listen bro
I got concealed carry and everything bro
within the next few minutes officers
realize their mistake
I did AR
en't good
things good on them
[Applause]
everything's good on it
they're out of Arizona
Arizona Arkansas
AR for Arkansas
so this is my this is my initial one
right here
Arizona though
Arizona
oh I see what you're saying yeah
everything matches up perfectly that's
all me
explain everything yeah I know I'm just
get it figured out
is everybody back over there when
officials confirm there's been a mishap
they put down their weapons Hi man
listen this is a it was an honest
mistake
okay
there's a long call we didn't know okay
normally when we say
the vehicles
so it came and we thought it was a
stolen vehicle when we ran the
information it came back stolen to us
and so
um this is the normal way we uh pull
people out of a stolen car okay it just
came back to us that it was not stolen
so that's why we stopped everything in
the middle otherwise all four of y'all
would have came out of gunpoint right so
as soon as it came into the system
that's when we like time out time out
time out you understand okay we're so
sorry that you got to go through that
yeah
she got this one in 2019. she got this
in 2019 before before she had she had a
Chrysler 200 I believe let me go look
see what's going do you have any other
paperwork for the vehicle oh probably
the insurance I got the insurance
[Applause]
[Music]
hey there's an ID right there next year
behind your right foot
everything yeah
so look see
you filming the channel
[Applause]
can I answer the phone that's my brother
what the glove box
we don't need any assistance
[Applause]
yeah I was on tollway South and no one
else was close
The Tackle is not good it's good you ran
out of the wrong State something's good
on her
man yeah I mean I'm so sorry man bro
so like this is normal standard protocol
any stolen vehicle this is called a high
risk traffic
no it's got a high risk half sock every
any stolen vehicle I mean person that
left the scene of like a robber like
with guns involved right right you
always like we don't ever go up to them
we always call them out to us
with the gun I'm like damn what the
we do I just ate breakfast you know what
I'm saying yeah
hey man don't let this affect your game
hey look at me
so what happened was we stopped the car
because it came back to a stolen vehicle
okay a stolen charger everything like it
matched everything
it's crazy it's just I don't know how it
happened
so
she pulls up she stops you then I was
the second one to roll out and then we
do this it's a normal thing for all it's
called a high-risk traffic stop y'all
can YouTube it high risk traffic stop
okay every hybrid any kind of stolen
vehicle we're trained to pull them out
like that we talked to the driver pull
them out
the only reason why we had to do it this
way yeah because y'all were against the
wall so we couldn't get those guys out
that's why you came second you know what
I mean
yeah first house
[Applause]
that's awesome
it's great boys
affect your game guys the officer
responsible for the error can then be
heard explaining her mistake
I ran at AZ for Arizona instead of AR
and that's what happened
I made a mistake
it could have went all wrong for us
though what do you mean by that I'm just
saying I wonder because like I say I
dropped my phone here they yelled out
don't move or we'll shoot till I dropped
my phone if I would have went to reach
for my phone we could have all got
together
this
[Applause]
we make mistakes
foreign
[Applause]
the same moments can be seen from
another angle
looks like I made a mistake so I ran it
easy for Arizona to the AR and that's
what happened yeah
[Applause]
I'm just saying I wonder because like I
said I dropped my phone here like yeah
that don't move but we'll shoot and I
dropped my phone if I would have went to
reach for my phone that's why we get
clear instructions no we get that's why
we're giving you themselves
you know we're so sorry if it happened
like this we had no intent on
on doing this you know
we're humans as well and we make we make
mistakes right I'm not justifying
anything I'm just saying
like it wasn't a computer that read it
it was our human error that did this and
so please forgive us
[Applause]
I'm sorry man
sorry brother okay
[Applause]
for now
but man we I'm gonna be honest man being
on the scene being on the scene knowing
that children were involved that's why
we were moving so slow we were
apprehensive brother you know I mean we
weren't trying to like be all fast and
stuff that's why
oh yeah
sounds good you just he's just going
through the whole emotions of like you
know what it could have been you know
which is very legitimate I mean I get it
man
your feelings are Justified man your
your fears and all that's Justified but
but like you saw during the situation
everything you cooperate That's How It
Ends every time right that's how I tell
her all the time
I gotta find the place for the cowboy
that's on the same thing y'all cooperate
nothing's gonna happen no one just
randomly shoots somebody for no reason
right yeah that's why we said please
don't reach the call we know there's a
gun in there and y'all did everything
right you know what I'm saying officers
then explained that a vehicle with the
same make model and color was reported
missing out of Arizona further leading
to the mistake it was
she typed in the wrong
even put the AR for the short
abbreviation for the should put a z was
it Arizona
so what happened is she put in the wrong
State what you typed it in that exactly
it came back to a black Dodge Charger
as well in Arizona and a stolen black
charger
so it came up solar vehicle stolen
vehicle stolen vehicles stolen vehicle
but she typing AZ instead of a r
that's the mind-blowing thing like
Oklahoma at work whatever it may come
back to a
Ford F-150 like how is it going to come
back to the exact car color exact model
and make
I mean it was just like coincidental but
man I'm so sorry y'all had to deal with
that man okay hey look at me I'm really
sorry okay
you're really sorry man again the
officer responsible for the license
plate error apologizes taking
responsibility for the issue
[Applause]
okay I apologize for this I know Birds
matter for you and your nephew being so
um and like I said it's on me
if you have any questions this is my
sergeant here doing questions for him
like I was telling him
y'all cooperate that's never going to
happen
I see new stories but if you cooperate
don't do anything wrong
okay
[Applause]
the woman claiming to be The Driver of
the vehicle said the incident caused
mental and emotional trauma for her
family this has been the most exhausting
and the most traumatizing and just I've
never been in trouble a day in my life I
may have a speeding ticket or something
but I don't I'm a hard-working woman I'm
a nurse I just I don't my son is in a
great school he's very involved in
sports and just a number I just it just
I can't make sense of this I can't and
I've cried all day today I have I'm
running off of maybe two two and a half
hours of sleep
this is just I it's just I can't make
sense of it the Frisco police chief has
since released a statement about the
incident saying in part quote our
department will not hide from its
mistakes instead we will learn from them
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie